when i was trying to leave the air force
and anyone who has transitioned out of
the military knows what this feels like
you're like what the hell can i do like
in one in one way you're like the whole
world is an option and then in the other
side you're like i only do one thing in
uniform and nobody needs that out there
so in my kind of frustrated attempts to
figure out where i fit in that was when
i just boiled myself down to well what
am i like what are the things i really
want here at 27. i want to travel the
world not just the world but like the
armpit of the world i want to see the
shittiest parts of the world because i
was able to see some shitty parts of the
world with the air force and it really
made me proud to be an american
so i was like i want to see more shitty
parts of the world because it's just
going to make my confidence and my
my appreciation for my country that much
firmer so i was looking for africa i was
looking for like hardship
and i was looking for a lady with hairy
armpits and hairy legs that wanted to
get it on and attend in africa those are
the two things i was looking for peace
corps was going to deliver wow but
halfway through that application
you have
but
i won't understand how the cia works
something popped up on your screen
was that intentional or is that
accidental you know what you see what
i'm asking so you gotta remember the
government works like one giant organism
and the the peace corps is part of the
government state department is part of
the government dhs is part of the
government fbi is part of the government
the u.s military is part of the
government my entire record
going back to the age of 18 was on file
my name was in capital letters which
means i'm an asset of the us government
right that's that's what they saw so
when i started applying to another
government agency
i fell into some massive algorithm
somewhere and happened to hit on what
they were looking for just like a
keyword search anywhere else got it and
i got a warning screen that popped up in
the middle of my online application to
peace corps a screen that said hey you
may qualify for other opportunities big
red screen
please put this application on hold
and we'll reach out to you within 72
hours if if you were to have the same
thing happen yeah big red screen says
hey you may qualify for other
opportunities and you're 27 years old
how how easy is it to click that button
and says yes put me on hold
and that's how that's how they found me
and then from that point forward it's
just that application was abandoned and
a new application was created so it
wasn't it's not a word of mouth uh
method of recruiting they have multiple
cia has multiple ways of recruiting
there is word of mouth for sure there's
word of mouth and that's for a very deep
cover
kind of niche area because there you
you're looking for people with
established credibility and in some
special field so
it's not easy to find business people
who are actually running successful
businesses and then you want to turn
them into spies that's that's a hard
thing to do so you look for word of
mouth and then you have things like the
government world anybody trying to move
from one government job to another
government job that can be automated
that's easy and then you've got the
whole world of college recruiting where
you have
either somebody who's a recruiter on
campus or somebody who's a regional
recruiter that visits multiple campuses
and you will literally find cia in a
cheesy stall
with a sign at almost every college
recruiting event for big colleges pat
you told the story that
your dad pulled you aside one day and
he's like
you can tell me son
it's okay just you can tell me you were
in the army
uh 101st right and your dad literally
thought
you were doing something else what was
that this was five six years ago he says
you know it's five six years ago six
years you're already running php
this is six years ago this is maybe five
to seven years ago where he's like you
can tell me you know we have people in
the family i'm like that i'm telling you
i'm not he says i understand if you are.
i said that first of all i'm not he says
i know even if you were you couldn't
tell me i said i'm telling you right now
i'm not so
till today there's a 20 chance
he legitimately thought you could have
been something in the intelligence
community cia what have you yeah
i don't even know where the speculation
for him can he just one day came up to
me we're having dinner and he asked me a
question he says i've been really
thinking about this i don't know how to
ask you without offending you yeah he
says are you i said i'm i'm telling you
i'm not
he says i understand and he keeps and i
understand like yeah
i'm telling you i'm not but
he's your dad man
so your dad your dad always thinks that
you're the best your dad always thinks
that you're the most elite right like
that's an awesome dad so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]